- Jake, would you rather
have tiny, tiny hands,
like hands smaller than an
avocado, or a giant tongue,
like the biggest tongue,
like the size of a Nerf ball
that's like a big
problem for you?
It's like a situation, and
you can't close your mouth,
and it's always hanging
out of your mouth.
For me, I'd go with the tiny
hands, because you can always
just put them in your
pocket, and then boom,
no more problem.
But with a tongue, it's like
you might as well be wearing
a shirt that says look
at my big giant tongue.
This is a giant problem for me
right now, and at all times.
So what's your preference?
What would you rather do?
Jake?
- I'd rather have regular
hands and a regular tongue.
- Right, but that's not what--
- That's what I want!